if you can psychoanalyze jack dorsey for
a second
so he's one of the early adopters or
he's one of the people pushing the early
adoption in this layer three
so inside cash app what do you make of
the man
of this decision
as a business owner
as somebody playing in the space like
what um
why did he do it and
what does that mean for others
at the scale that might be doing the
same so incorporating lightning
networking incorporating bitcoin into
their products
i think he's been pretty clear about
this
he feels that bitcoin is an instrument
of economic empowerment for billions of
people that are unbanked and have no
property rights
in the world
if you want to give
an incorruptible bank
to 8 billion people on the planet
that's the same as asking the question
how do you give a full education
through phd to 8 billion people on the
planet
and the answer is
a a digital version
of the 20th century thing running on a
mobile phone
and bitcoin is a bank in cyberspace it's
run by uncorruptable software and it's
for everybody on earth
so i think when jack looks at it he's
very sensitive to the plight of
everybody in africa
if you look at africans right like
you're going to give them banks you're
not going to put a bank branch on every
corner that's an obscene waste of energy
you're not going to run copper wires
across the continent that's an obscene
waste of energy
you're not gonna
give them gold and you know so so how
are you going to
provide people with a decent life
that the metaphor i think is is relevant
here the biological metaphor lex is uh
type 1 diabetic
if you're a type 1 diabetic you can't
form fat and if you can't form fat
then you can't store excess energy so
that means that i mean fat is the
ultimate organic battery and if you've
got 30 pounds of it you can go 60 days
without eating
but if you can't
generate insulin you can't form fat
cells and you can't form fat cells and
store energy then you can eat yourself
to death i mean you will eat and you
will die you'll starve to death
so the lack of property rights
is like being a type 1 diabetic
and so if you look at most people
everywhere in the world
they don't have property rights
they don't have effective bank and they
don't and their currency is broken
like what what are the two things that
in theory would serve as the equivalent
of a of uh
an organic battery or an economic
battery to civilization it would be
i have a currency which holds its value
and i can store it in a bank so a risk
a risk-free
currency derivative
i yeah i pay you your money you take
your life savings you put it in the bank
you save up for your retirement you live
happily ever after that's the american
dream
right that's the idyllic situation
the real situation is
there are no banks you can't get a bank
account so i give you your pay in
currency and then i double the supply
and i give it to my cousin
or i give it to whatever cause i want or
i use it to buy weapons and then you
find a loaf of bread cost triple next
month is what it cost and your life
savings is worthless
and so in that environment
everybody's ripped back to stone age
barter
and the problem with that even stone age
barter is
you're going to carry your life savings
on your back and what happens when the
guy with a machine gun points it at your
head and just takes your life saving so
so i think from jack's point of view
he thinks that life is
this is maybe too strong but i these are
my words life is hopeless for a lot of
people
and bitcoin is hope
right because because it it gives
everyone
um
an engineered
monetary asset that's a bearer
instrument
and it gives them a bank on their mobile
phone
and they they don't have to trust their
government or another counterparty
with
their life force
so
i there's a secondary thing i think he's
interested in which is
the first thing is the human rights
issue and the second thing would be
the friction to to trade cross borders
is so great right
yeah like
i i you know you like a.i
so i'll give you a beautiful notion
maybe one day there'll be an
artificially intelligent creature in
cyberspace
that is self-sufficient and rich
like that we would have sovereignty
can a robot
own money or property
how about kind of tesla car can i
actually put enough muff money in a car
for it to drive itself and maintain
itself forever or can i create an
artificially intelligent creature in
cyberspace that is endowed
such that it would live a thousand years
and continue to do its job
right
you know we have a word for that in the
real world it's institution harvard
cambridge stanford right there are
institutions with endowments that go on
in perpetuity
but what if i wanted to perpetuate um
a software program
and um
with uh with something like digital
property with bitcoin and lightning
you could do it
and on the other hand
with uh banks and credit cards
you couldn't
right
you couldn't ever so so you can create
things that are beautiful
and lasting
and
what's the difference in speed well
so
i can either trade with everybody in the
world
at the speed of light friction free in
24 hours writing a python script or
i can spend 100 billion dollars to trade
with a few million people in the world
after it takes them six months
of application the impedance
is like a 10 million to one difference
right and the metaphors are literally
like launching something in orbit versus
almost orbit or vacuum sealing something
does it last forever and does it orbit
forever or does it go up and come down
and burn up
right and i think jack is interested in
you know
putting freedom in orbit all right
putting putting freedom in orbit and he
said many times he said this is the the
internet needs a native currency yeah
right and and
no political construct or security
can be a native currency you need a
property and you need a property that
can be moved a million times a second
can you oscillate it at 10 kilohertz or
100
kilohertz and the answer is
only
if it's a pure digital construct
permissionless and open and so i think
he that he's enthusiastic as the
technologist and he's enthusiastic as
the humanitarian
and what he's doing
is uh to support both those areas he's
supporting the bitcoin and the lightning
protocol by building them into his
products but he's also building the
applications
which you need at the cash app level in
order to commercialize
and deliver the functionality and
compliance necessary and
they're related
and
i should also say he's just a
fascinating person i
for a random reason
that i couldn't even explain if i tried
i met him
a few days ago and gave him a great big
hug in the middle of nowhere there was
no explanation he just appeared that's a
fascinating human his relationship with
art with the world with human suffering
with technology is fascinating
um don't i don't know what his path
looks like but it's interesting that
people like that exist
um and in part i'm saddened that he no
longer is involved with twitter
directly as a ceo
because i was hoping something inside
twitter would also
integrate some of these ideas
of uh what you're calling digital energy
um to see how social networks something
i'm really interested in and passionate
about could be transformed
you